va bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo momento io sono fatti j oggi
siamo tornati su youtube live allo
ragazzi è da una vita che non ci gioco
perché io l'avevo registrato prima di
andare a los angeles quindi non mi
ricordo neanche più dov'eravamo rimasti
va bene zia ascoltami non ho capito bene
che cosa dobbiamo fare ma nel dubbio
mangiamo a prescindere o ragazza o 60
mila iscritti e c'è tanta roba sono
quasi anche un milione di views totali
fantastico slip perché grandi youtuber
devono dormire sono caz lo swatch adesso
qualcosa per raggiungere il traguardo
dei video più visti sono quasi un
milione ce la sto per fare dai dai dai
ha dormito o quest'altro ecco fosse così
facile fare il letto la mattina anche io
lo faccio così la mattina solo che non
funziona un cazzo mi vien subito chi sei
donna ma [ __ ]
sono venuto a giocare ma che cosa vuoi
eve basta eve ribalta fatti una vita vai
a casa tua
veramente ho il potere sulle donne non
ci posso credere a facciamo collo fiori
che l'ultima volta mi pare che sia
andato bene quindi walk through sapere
ho cacciato la mia ragazza e
incredibilmente mia cagato ora sono
single
ieri ragazze cambiato il gioco è diverso
hai ucciso venti nemici prima di morire
è la madonna roccioso forte cambiato un
sacco giuro hanno aggiunto l'ex lecce
anche la preview adesso non ci credo
hanno aggiunto nelle cose stupende rega
fantastico che è il pubblico video però
fa vj sono un grande tua fan ecco
ragazzo hai avuto il mio numero sono
grande fan e mi piace parlare con te
voglio dirti che sei fantastico mi
piacciono i tuoi video grazie
dopo aver parlato con questo fan per un
po hai realizzato che in realtà era un
frank fa come alcuni scritti non ti
rispettano più ma perché ma cosa c'entro
io se lo hanno fatto un prestito ionici
aveva bisogno di views sto mentecatto
che doveva mi prendeva bene che cosa
c'entro io canto si scrivono ho perso 5
per cento nei miei scritti basse hai
pagato le tue
tasse mensili 80 solo 80 dollari cosa è
venuto a fare quella cosa viene a fare
quella ragazza in camera mia ogni volta
che se ne va a dio mio vuoi chiudere a
chiave per cortesia che la o mio nome
isabel vorremmo offrirti una carta che
ti dà un sacco di sconti ma [ __ ]
esplodi ma come ho perso 5 per cento di
iscritti ma perché faranno che ha visto
non ho capito il senso perché perdo
iscritti la gente mi chiama al telefono
sti [ __ ] ho perso diecimila iscritti
tre secondi avevo 60mila per possiamo
ricaricare il video da zero stavo
scherzando non hanno giocato io in
realtà questo gioco io che mi chalfant
vigevano invitarti a vedere dei film e
va bene cosa fa questa qui bio mio ogni
volta levati dalle associate ad asso e
va bene a santo gesù santo cioè veri
tesoro registra un blog possono gare sta
registrando introiti loro mica in un
cinema vela tutti ragazzi e ben vedere
sonori in un cinema ti sei reso conto
che questa immagine sfocata amica quanto
e quante volte mi succede quando blocco
io
off topic comment giusto o filmato una
bella gnocca che me la voleva dare
chiedi ai tuoi scritti di mettere mi
piace va bene ok finito dividerlo
eviterò quando sarò a casa abete credo
se ti metti a evitare al cinema è un
caso ho perso e credimi è veri meriti
video ti posso abbracciare grazie tu si
che sei una bella [ __ ] cipro basta
che poi mi si sversino al personaggio
che questo tizio che stai rimorchiando
questa tipa posso rimorchiarla io
ciao zio tu non sei più interessante
levati dal cattura come mi controlla la
mia ragazza che mi segue e lasciami
libero donna io ho una mia vita senti
zia devi farti una vita che non viviamo
insieme non siamo sposati lotti 1 mito
signor bodyguard mista importunandola
butti fuori la butti fuori mazza che i
bodyguard valoroso ti puoi rimorchiare
la mia tipa per favore che mi dà
fastidio
va bene elevati che ci sono io levati
conosce importante non sia importante
togliti ora mi sta mettendo avanti alle
fotocamere zia ti devi togliere mi dai
fastidio grazie espressi ti devi
togliere che palle sempre messa i
[ __ ] grazie però poi anche uscire
perché non sei abbastanza famoso questo
qua continua a dirmi ste cose enter the
all
speriamo ci sto film abbiamo che fini
sia mi fate vedere il film per cortesia
che l'ultima volta non si è riuscito
avere niente madonna quanto vi ammazzare
le famiglie e belle queste piastrelle
del cinema lo sai che quella fianco a me
appena scoraggiato mi piace questo film
lo so che lo stai guardando solo perché
c'è di caprio brutta [ __ ] alza ci vai a
prendere i pop corn dai che non c'è
voglia di muovere il culo è finito che
va bene torniamo a casa è stato
veramente un film indimenticabile sono
gesu solo il giusto ricevendo la
misericordia cos'è successo non fermi
non ho capito sesta sono salito di
livello dai perdendo iscritti ho capito
non mi fa creare il video che dopo che
faccia ok a perfetto e iscrivetevi
minchioni è che palle e iscrivetevi
minchioni mica farò un successo
si prostrano mi capita anche a me di
esser contento dei miei video è vero dio
mio avo ragazzi vediamo di comprare
qualcosa che mi chiama e va bene o
aspettare che vi do carichi computer di
merda c'hai
4 ore workshop buy a lavare la macchina
deficiente guadagnati sti 20 dollari dio
mio no come quelli che fanno youtuber
come lavoro fa il lavoro vero deficiente
ok la vj sono uno dei tuoi grandi fan e
se mi stai piglia x culo ti darò 30
dollari per una plenty share
mi da 30 dollari per una mia t shirt
bene mi ha dato 30 dollari ma ho perso
il 5 per cento di iscritti ma perché che
il problema chan nei miei scritti se
vendo una maglietta a progresso visto
guadagnando di bruno mai via donna che
sto lavorando a fare un video ti manderò
gioso va bene
minchia quanto pid avere la vonn ei play
studios 2 va bene allora mi devo
comprare una o nei play studios perché
sennò coca tedesca falso video mica
quanto e visa ha fatto iscrivetevi
minchioni coni play studios 253 dollari
ma neanche tanto peso o peggio
vai compra tissima era una donna
arrivata subito hanno arrivato prima
gioco giusto quando che mi arriva
congratuli show non se il 66esimo ma la
faq ruolo hanno messo risparmio più
comuni di internet tipo se il nostro 600
66esimo visitatore nella prossima patch
che faranno i sto gioco aggiungeranno
ragazzi sono veramente euforico sono
veramente euforico ragazzi un open
placed trovato una playstation che è
andata a sostituire l'xbox ovviamente
mio gaming mica quanto sta facendo sto
video hazard cooking verso tutti gli
scream e impressioni ho fatto questo
video per soldi con una vero come lo
scritto male dio mio guarda quanti
incazzato quando giocava playstation sé
ma zio stai calmo sembra che s'erano
orgasmo santo iddio ce l'abbiamo fatta
regalo devi toglierti donna sto giocando
io per fare un video che cosa vuole
quanto nervoso mi da questa non avete
idea processo non può pagare video in se
però devo pubblica per forza perché
ormai ho registrato a sono gli 8 milioni
di views un milione di views allora
invece imparare il computer non possiamo
è la madonna quanto ha fatto schifo
quanto sto perdendo iscritti per questo
video va da onna che roba orribile è
stata prima subito un hd money
perché prima non c'avevo e questo è però
non c'è abbastanza soldi ma dai mi
dovrebbe dare dei soldi quella tipa luce
di come microfono è la cosa più bella di
questo mondo rega bello bene è molto più
figo sì ma la tipa ai 350 miliardi di
dollari che mi deve l'ho fatto è a walk
through io non ho fatto mai fuso stupido
non ho fatto il walk through ho fatto un
altro tipo di video imortacci de tomaso
[Musica]
demoris e il cugino non ci posso credere
ragazzi ci ho messo anche poi non mi va
neanche il computer o sbagliate volevo
fare la walk through
sì va be ma mi chiami compito sa
veramente implodendo rega 40 dollari
odore a fare la hostess e facciamo la
stessa veloce zio vai a fare la hostess
mentre carica il video io vi giuro che
sono nelle esasperazioni più totale
della vita sono dopo disappointed grazie
l'hai fatto perfettamente il video
grazie zia sgancia limone e brava
fratella questo volevo dio mio che non
rimpiazzarmi computer vai a casa tua
momento incredibile della vita al nuovo
computer e sta roba qua mi ha svoltato
la giornata nuova tastiera monitor l'ho
appena comprato tutto capita si è rotto
il cazzo è premuto sto cambiando
microfono al 2 j diceva sto comprando le
cose non mi mollare ti prego non mi
mollare
sto comprando le cose se devo riparare
il computer solo per comprarmi un altro
computer mi incazzo ok devi solo andare
su internet e comprare un altro computer
bassa di fare nient'altro compra c'è un
altro computer zio
ti prego iddio compratelo dimmi che io
io io devo spendere 100 fottuti dollari
per poi fare upgrade e comprarmi un
altro computer vi rendete conto del
problema [ __ ] laida firth che ho
speso 100 dollari per rimpiazzarmi
computer per poi ricomprarlo perchè
perchè non potevi andare solo su google
non avete idea della rogna che ciò
addosso in questo istante ragazzi
praticamente io ragazzi ho buttato 100
dollari
ne ho preso io pure ho preso io presi e
io buttati nel cesso sono tuo padre ma
[ __ ] comandato il video 50 è la
madonna 52 mila views mica tantissimo ha
fatto un sacco di chiusura calvi da me
almeno come amica una notizia positiva
ma ho fatto una tragedia in un giorno
solo micari in piazza mi sto computer ti
prego ma non lo potevo più vedere guarda
non lo potevo più vedere orribile dei
ragazzi io concludo qui l'episodio
perché sono veramente incazz no io
veramente non va bè ragazzi spero che
sia piaciuto lasciato bene mi piace
almeno qui santo ed io spero che vi
siete 100 ragazzi come se vi è piaciuta
sull'argomento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come noi video
totale descrizione sono stati scritti ci
mettiamo subito quando ce vo ce vo